pues a más de una semana del comienzo de
la guerra en ucrania la llegada de
refugiados a este punto fronterizo de
polonia está empezando a descontrolarse
vemos que cada vez llega hasta aquí más
gente ayer por ejemplo supimos que hasta
8 mil ucranianos estaban en la frontera
esperando para poder entrar en polonia y
vemos que la situación se está
descontrolando porque cada vez hay más
gente esperando y también porque vemos
cada vez más por ejemplo agentes de
seguridad o también personal sanitario
ya que entre la gran multitud de
ucranianos que están llegando hasta este
punto pues hay muchas mujeres
embarazadas y también personas con
algunas enfermedades o incluso algunos
discapacitados mentales este centro
comercial que veis aquí detrás empezó
siendo un lugar de refugio donde algunos
ucranianos se metían para poder pasar la
noche pero se ha terminado convirtiendo
en menos de 24 horas en el centro del
transporte es decir se están
redistribuyendo a los ucranianos según
el lugar del destino cada sala es uno de
los países a los que los ucranianos
quieren dirigirse por ejemplo los que
tienen hasta berlín tienen una zona
y otra sala para los que van hacia
españa hacia italia o incluso a las
distintas ciudades de polonia y es hasta
aquí hasta este centro comercial a donde
los voluntarios de todos los países de
europa están viniendo para ofrecer sitio
en sus vehículos en sus caravanas en sus
autobuses para poder distribuir a los
ucranianos por otros puntos de este
continente una vez que entran tienen que
registrarse dar un carnet de identidad y
decir cuánta capacidad tienen y es
entonces cuando ya pueden llevarse a los
refugiados ucranianos que puedan para
incluso alojar los en sus casas en otros
países de europa